[Music]
big shot gangster putting together crew
you in wait a long time for a shot like
this what are you doing with having the
boy
we need a ship the Millennium Falcon
every ship isn't for everyone
she needs a particular type of pilot
done flirting
these people not your friends
there's a lesson to be learned here
got a really good feeling about this
[Music]
[Music]
you're after something
[Music]
is it revenge
money
or is it something else you look good
little rough around the edges but good
heard about a job big shot gangster
putting together crew
I'm a driver and I'm a flier
the waited a long time for a shot like
this what do you think well what do you
know you got a line on the ship
yeah no guy either by smuggler around I
heard a story about you I was wondering
if it's true everything you read about
me it's true l-3 let's go with a mean
man's face who are these guys
if you come with us you're in this life
for good might wanna buckle up baby
[Music]
let me give you some advice assume
everyone will betray you
and you'll never be disappointed I got a
really good feeling about this
when do you know how to fly me a hundred
and ninety years old look great
[Music]
you
you